[Music]
more news here at four o'clock a new
details about a new resort near the las
vegas strip the majestic slated to be
built early next year in fact it's right
across the street from the brand new
convention center joe mohler joining us
now live from that area with what we
know about this project joe
denise is getting busy over here with
the new convention center hall here this
is that lot where that majestic hotel
will be built the posters and the
development uh
board outside here have been here for
some time and we expect the construction
to have started already this year we
learned this new non-gaming hotel will
break ground early 2022.
according to the majestic website and
county officials the majestic will break
ground in the first quarter of next year
the website describes a non-gaming and
non-smoking ultra luxury hotel that
could attract a whole new visitor to las
vegas its opening date is listed as
2024.
this is just down the street from las
vegas newest resort resorts world county
commissioner tick sigerblum says the
future of the north end of his trip is
bright the north part of the strip is on
fire i mean it may take a few more
years to fully
implement but the truth is that's where
all the action is
now back out here live another
development we are also learning more
information about is the former fountain
blue the big blue building towering over
the strip we have some new information
that the jw marriott that was supposed
to go there is no longer going to be
part of that project we'll update you
here at six o'clock on eight news now
for the very latest on that reporting
live joe mohler live local now